se mettre des chèques oublient une règle
importante je vais essayer de le faire
tomber notre ami je vais essayer de le
faire tomber
[Musique]
attends mais si je pousse si je pousse
il est pas dans le Carex on voit en fait
si je pousse je vais à Damme je sais
tout ça mais je suis débile juste je
pousse bah oui bah tu as plus qu'à
abandonner gros c'est fini tu me
rattrapes jamais avec ton bras tu cours
pas assez vite c'est Dame ça me paraît
chaque année en France la prise en
passant provoque 1386 factures de coccyx
7892 souris cassé 6545 et crans brisée
pour votre santé celle de votre
ordinateur faites attention aux pions
qui avance de cases
[Musique]